There was a study in the 70s Robert Glass and his team, I think, where they locked people in
rooms and blasted them with noise. Not the kind that follows a pattern, mind you. No, this was the
chaotic kind, the kind that doesn't announce itself, that sneaks up on you like a bad thought.
And here's the kicker. Even after the noise stopped, the damage was done. Their brains had
taken a hit. They called it post-noise impairment. A fancy term for what happens when your mind gets
too tired to think straight. But the real twist? Give those same people a button. Tell them they
can press it to make the noise go away. And what happens? Their brains don't even flinch. Not
because they pressed it. Because they thought they could. Ah, there it is. To craft world-class misery,
you don't need a button at all. You need to make sure there isn't one. Silence is the enemy. Not
the kind that cradles you. Not the kind that lets your thoughts settle like dust on an old shelf.
No, silence is the ultimate betrayal. In silence, your brain starts asking questions. Why am I like
this? What if I tried something different? What if I just stop? And that's when the real work begins.
So you drown it out. You fill the air with noise, not just any noise, but the kind that sticks to your
skin like static. The digital hum of a laptop left open to some half-watched video. The muffled drone
of a podcast you've long since stopped listening to. The content doesn't matter. What matters is the
fullness of it. The way it presses against your ears like a second skin. Your nervous system doesn't know
the difference between a threat and a distraction, so it stays on edge. Always. Exhausted. Too busy to
wander. And then there are the headphones. Not the kind you use to listen, but the kind you wear like
armor. Noise-canceling, of all things. Because nothing says I am unavailable to my own thoughts
like blocking out the world while still drowning in it. You might as well be screaming into a pillow.
If you want to really commit, you curate your soundscape like a master of misery. Talk radio,
maybe. The kind that thrives on outrage where every syllable is a nail driven deeper into your stress
response. Or news programs that treat conflict like entertainment. Because nothing keeps your
cortisol levels humming like a steady diet of other people's chaos. And if you're feeling particularly
ambitious, thin walls. No sound-proofing. Let the neighbor's vacuum become a recurring character in
your mental theater. A guest who never leaves. The goal isn't just distraction. It's saturation. By the
time you've reached the 160th page of your year whatever that means to you, you should have forgotten
what your own voice sounds like in an empty room. You'll be so deep in the noise that your unhappiness
isn't just background music anymore. It's the only thing you can hear. And that, my friend, is the
muffled mind. There's a log entry for March 19th Taf Residence Log, they called it, where some poor
soul sits in a kitchen at three in the morning, stirring coffee while the refrigerator hums like
a bad conscience. The combination is perfect. The caffeine jitters, the ambient drone, the way the
noise and the chemicals work together to turn your thoughts into static. It's not just a way to pass the
time. It's a ritual, a way to ensure that when the sun finally rises, you're already halfway to forgetting
what dawn even looks like. Silence is where the soul speaks. Noise is where it sleeps. And God help you
if you ever wake up.